we'll get five suggestions there'll be
one from each segment of the room and uh
what is going on here you're
automatically volunteering you're like
we're not even waiting we are huge hip
hop fans we've got a suggestion you've
got one what's it gonna be
you were walking and i'm just going to
say you were walking and a homeless guy
this could go one of two ways
either either he asked for money or you
saw a penis
he said
you'd be old but you'd be sexy he said
you'd be old but you'd be sexy
let me say it probably the best
compliment you're gonna get from a
homeless man right
[Applause]
okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i thought i thought you said it worked
and you were like just behind you sat
there just a guy like hello
[Laughter]
it's a great chat of line i'm gonna say
it guys i think it only works if you are
homeless i don't think
i don't think you could approach someone
at a bar and be like
you're aged but attractive
maybe with this accent it would maybe
with the
like
you're of elderly years but
still younger than the queen and she's a
she's a mama
okay you be old
but still sexy was that right
you'd be old but you'd be sexy amazing
sometimes i'm just like we don't need
more suggestions for the rap we could
just do that but um i feel like we
should add uh some more in so people
over here what would you like a wrapper
there's a hand up here from a man who
looks like you serial kill on the
weekends
it's the sideburns without the sideburns
you look like a lovely man with the
sideburns i'm like don't go near
sorority houses please
[Applause]
sorority houses are now on your mind
aren't they i
you also didn't deny what i said
you weren't even like nah not on the
weekends chris
weeknights okay keg stands yes keg
stands you be old but sexy and uh people
over here what would you like a wrap
about blow jobs for a clam shrouder
i think the man who said that thing to
you earlier might be in the back corner
over there
blow jobs for clam chowder
i apologize for making that joke i know
you're not uh that was not a masculine
voice
blow jobs for clam chowder is a
fantastic suggestion keg stands you'll
be all but you'll be sexy um back of the
room what do you like a rap about
daddy issues okay
how do your how do your daddy issues um
express themselves
[Applause]
that's that's how your daddy issues
express themselves
through parkinson's okay
wow
i mean that is a brutal brutal illness
i mean like it feels weird cause like
this is gonna be really fun that's gonna
be kind of fun that's gonna be fun
that'd be kind of fun real downer on
this one
okay um
sorry this side of the room you didn't
get to suggest anything i wish i wish
you had i wish you had i wish you'd for
taking that fifth suggestion space
okay cool so
to remind you all keg stand uvl but
you'll be sexy blow jobs for clam
chowder daddy issues and parkinson's
i might do them in that order i might
try and skate over that one in the
middle
i feel like the big finish can't be
life limiting illness
okay well um my lovely band they're
gonna set me up some lovely beats let's
see what we're gonna do
jesus christ red look at that
some
steel drums [ __ ]
this is new this is new this is exciting
um okay i'm feeling the vibe i'm feeling
the vibe and we'll start with you cool
fine ladies in the street one of them
checks me like oh i'll be old but i'm
still sexy how do you know the hobo told
me you stopped there in the middle froze
in the street like repeat that so
everybody hears he stands up lifts his
hat over his ears and says yeah i'm
gonna stare for days because these
ladies are fit considering their age you
don't need to qualify you can say
attractive a great topic for the rap and
we had this but this guy on my right
hand looking like a murderer but he can
do a keg stand he can invert that the
depravity that he does regularly but the
fire and gravity got the strong biceps
triceps too if i was a gymnast i'd
demonstrate to you but i'm not can't do
it it would evoke a smile if i was
standing on my arm strong like simone
biles no breath there you assume what i
said be simone biles that's the s and
the b i'm at a frat party sick in the
head i'm so drunk but still i be
slipping on kegs i'm like watch this
guys watch this band they stop marching
and then i tempt to stand it doesn't
work i fall over there i hate it i abhor
it i ain't got the health insurance
that's the problem with your country
back where i'm from we've got more we've
got it free going on but still if i'm in
new england i will allow a guy in my
mouth for a cup of cam chow cam clam you
gotta add the l i be going on my knees i
don't mind the smell the guy's not
homeless it's just a random dude he said
chris i was feeling in an oral mood and
i whipped up a batch of my clam soup
earlier and so i'm down there and i'm
serving you oh it's never so nice i'd be
fumbly and after he came i wasn't even
hungry it was so perfect he looked dishy
and like the clam chowder his [ __ ] tastes
fishy i apologize for that stuff that is
you in a tissue i've got daddy issues i
say papa why am i thanking probably i
walked in one time he was wanking and i
saw him i'm like i'll never get the
image out my eyeballs i see it and it's
not quite small it's average size
apologies dad he's not here tonight but
he would feel well sad if he knew i was
talking i'll give it a twirl flip it
round imagine that was not me but a girl
who was neglected her papa was never
there her mum wasn't she's great and she
really did care but maybe had a
different boyfriend every week the young
girl's like oh i really seek a strong
role model for which to follow but it
didn't work she ends up with this hobo
on the street outside he said the nicest
thing she feels a heart fluttering and
it brings tears to her eyes because
she's in her mid-50s and the homeless
man says you look nifty she says that'll
do we'll go to a room he says let me
tell you i'm gonna die soon she says why
that's a shame it's not fun he says i've
been diagnosed with parkinson's what are
the symptoms don't make a mistake it's
harder to work because your palms start
to shake i think it's like some
inhibitors in your nerves if you got it
it's not the end of your world you can
take medication do physical therapy
stills kind of not humorous or funny but
still we took it up yeah i can spit this
we finished the rap life limiting
illness
[Applause]